[Music]  first things first I'm so lonely lonely  huh my cat it's sometimes my pony pony  in my jammies and I'm feeling kind of  cozy I could sleep for days cuz I'm  creepy and I'm homely you should want a  bad [ __ ] like Diaz handshower than  weeks and I stink like deer here cup of  Vicks cup of tea cup of piss I feel like  broke boyfriend broke up with me and I'm  [ __ ] pissed off it'll be fun to help  me out with Taylor Swift fan and cheated  day is bring in hairy chicks bag oh  you're the books in Winnie sparks that  crochet swag  Daniel baby I'm so lonely you already  I'm in the slow lane from jammies to my  bathrobe coming go  who did oh yeah did you try to do Daniel  then I did you right over there oh did I  did you why do they do that how did you  why  [Music]